is that we're
live to youtube and that this meeting is
being recorded for the purposes
of the minutes thank you chair thank you
i thank everyone for the attendance
today and
we'll start the meeting do you have any
apologies for absence
don't receive chair thank you very much
do you have any declarations of interest
nobody could get a hand up thank you
we're on title number three then which
is minutes of the last meeting pages
five to seven
to approve as a correct record um
for the last meeting does anyone have
any comments or questions
happy to move chair okay
draw a seconder
yeah absolutely okay
all those four
any against any abstentions
thank you move on to item number four
then
which is the healthy partnership working
and to consider the progress of the
council's partnership
and i believe we have
[Applause]
moved to the pages
it is page 8-16
and you're back and we should have tris
burdette
joining us chair at this stage she's in
the
waiting room chair if you'd like me to
admit them
yes please
[Music]
good afternoon tris thank you for coming
is it okay if i call you truth is that
okay yep yep no that's fine
um do you need any introductions to
people on communities are you okay
uh yeah no i think i think i pretty much
know of everybody
but andy we've all got names at the
bottom anyway
thank you thank you for the report
i was just going to get you to highlight
any key points within the report
and and then if it's okay will you take
some questions at the end if that's all
right
yeah yeah no that's fine um
do you want me to share the report or um
damon do you want to share it
have you got access to it
it's a general agenda item number four
we've all got it in our packs so we
shall have a hard copy
if anyone wants to know i'm happy to
share it on screen but
apart from that we've all got a copy
anyway thank you no that's fine then
i'll
i'll just refer to my to my copy just
bear with me thank you
um yes so
um so today
i'm here just to talk about the healthy
north east derbyshire partnership
um and a review of um
what's what's been progressed um over
the last 12 months
um for those of you not familiar with
the partnership
um it is um funded fully funded by
public health
at derbyshire county council and is
chaired by the localities lead for
the area um our role is in
i'm the partnership development officer
and i work in the partnership strategy
team
here at northeast um and so
we manage the funding and managing the
commissioning of the projects
um on the wishes of the partnership um
the key membership
um includes um various services
from northeast and from derbyshire
county council retinal homes
uh the clinical commissioning group
primary care network
and the voluntary sector and the group
itself the partnership sorry was
established in 2015 so it's been going
for some time
um in the last few years the partnership
has had an allocation
of just over 69 and a half thousand
pounds
um which is it like i say it has been
annual and on top of that
and public health will also give us
discreet pots of funding for specific
activities
um which will be ring fenced um for
certain things so
more recently um we received over 50 000
pounds for social connectedness project
which i will talk about later
um one thing as well to say is that each
of the districts and boroughs within
the county has their own health
partnership
um and so this is the model that the
public health have
developed that they devolve um the
funding to these individual partnerships
um so if i just move on to the health
priorities
the main driver the main priority for
this particular partnership is all the
people
and about maintaining that independence
in the home
for as long as possible and also
um trying to support people with
long-term long-term health conditions
saying that though it is underpinned by
by three other priorities which is about
um building health communities
um you know building social capital
getting that sustainability in
um reducing wider determinants of health
obviously building healthy lifestyles as
well
um and um enabling people to access
effective health and social care but
as i previously said it's about kind of
all older people primarily
um what i should
what i need to say is obviously covid
has had
an impact on the activity
um that we've supported this last year
um
most projects have been able to adapt um
but obviously
completely unforeseen um so
and that has had an impact on um on what
we've been able to achieve
um you'll see within the report this um
the table
um lists the um projects that we're
currently supporting
um with an update on each so i'll just
i'll kind of just focusing on the bigger
projects if that's all right
but i'm going to go through one by one
um
yeah if i can um draw your attention to
um the small grants scheme um which is
on the
second part of the table um
this is ring fenced money in addition
that comes from county
um and this is um to fund
um community groups volunteer groups in
the district
obviously with a with a health physical
health and mental health
and focus um one of the things that's
happened this year is we've had
a low take up because groups have not
been meeting
the groups that have been running and
that have um had some kovac
specific activities have been able to
access the
kobe 19 recovery fund um organized and
and
um distributed by county council so what
we've done with the small grants is
um we're rolling the money forward um
i'm merging that with the five ways to
well-being which
that was particularly focused on mental
health but to enable
groups to have easier access to the
funding um
the pots are going to be merged together
and this is an approach that's going to
be used in chesterfield and bowls over
as well
um derbyshire voluntary action
administer the fund
um and um and they administer
the footballs over in chesterfield so we
have quite a good um sort of like
linking an
overview particularly when we've got
groups and agencies that
um maybe chest field center-based but
they do support northeast residents so
um so with dva kind of overseeing the
three
that's really helpful um the community
development worker
i'll come on to because i've got a
section in the report
about that um
the other um the other thing i just
wanted to mention was walk into
communities
now i understand you received a report
from kelly massey um
at the last meeting which obviously she
talked about has the service generally
um but um the walking into communities
offices
um we fund through the health
partnership
um and obviously and pre-covered
they were doing lots of good work in
terms of physical activity
um a lot of that had moved online and in
between the lockdown periods that we're
able to start running some of the
sessions again
in a covered safe environment but
obviously that has been affected but the
you know the aim is to get going with
that um
once uh once we're allowed um
the other the other project i wanted to
talk to you about was feeling connected
some of you may be aware of a recent
press release um
with regards to this project again this
was a discrete pot of money
that we receive from public health um
that the partnership received from
public health
and um we joined up with the
chesterfield health partnership
um and the premise of this project um
is to get people you know feeling more
socially connected
pre-covered a lot of work was done
around um
gathering stats and information just
looking to see where the gaps were
and then of course you know the world
changed in in march 2020 so
um momentum had slowed down a little bit
um during the course of last year but um
an action plan has been produced
recognizing the need for
for covid related um
recovery work um and so
now what what that project is aiming to
do is it's like a communications aspect
to it which is about
um raising the importance of um
feeling socially connected um and then
there's also
um a plan to have um targeted
um activity within the communities to to
help support
some of it's copied related and some of
it's more broader than that more about
you know sort of like general life after
covid
um so so that's quite a significant
project
um and then um just to touch upon the
together events
um the premise of this project was to
try and bring
residents together with key agencies and
services
um and so it's a bit of a kind of a meet
and mingle event
um we successfully held three in killer
marsh james moore
and north wingfield um but unfortunately
the last two that were supposed to be
held which was ringworm for neckington
and we had to cancel um the
previous events were well well attended
and we had good feedback
um so in order to sort of try and fill
fill the gap of the last two events um a
directory was produced
um other of those services and agencies
that would normally attend
um the together events um and
um they we managed to get two and a half
thousand booklets printed in the end
and they were distributed um in um
eckington and uh and winger with
um that we're hoping we can try and do
that again later on in the year
and because holding it holding an event
of that nature
is not going to happen anytime soon um
just to move on to the community
development worker
and this is a fully funded post through
the partnership
but we um the the officer actually sits
with us in the partnership team
um we've had different people um in the
role
um but the post has been established for
for over five years now
um one of the key um achievements
of that post is to uh maintain a
community health champion network
um and so this is about encouraging
people to volunteer
in their local communities um obviously
to
for their own health and mental health
well-being but also to benefit
um the local community as well um
and over the years um this the um
community development worker
has been able um to support volunteers
to help establish
youth groups um and um participate in um
sort of like local events parish events
um quite a few volunteers were involved
in food banks in certain areas
um helping neighbours friends and
and reducing that social isolation um
and one of the achievements was the um
sherlock community cafe which was
started um
and became self-sustaining and was being
run
by volunteers in the community
unfortunately that has stopped because
of covid but
um you know at some point it'd be nice
to think that that could
be up and running again and no
restrictions permitting
um but that was that was a well attended
you know 25 people on average a month
attending that so it was something that
you know the community needed
and um and the community led led that
um obviously within the last 12 months
um you know the people that are chcs a
lot of them have shield themselves and
that they've not been able to go out
um but um what um
the community development worker has
been doing is keeping in touch with
people remotely
providing information and signposting to
training
if anybody wants to do it online and and
what we wanted to do last year was a
celebration event
um to celebrate the achievements of the
volunteers
but we had to cancel it it was meant to
be held in june um
so we're hoping we can still run with
something at some point
um because it would be a shame to not um
you know to not celebrate the successes
of these individuals
um you know some of them have been
volunteering for
for quite some time um
so one thing i do want to say is
because of you know the the world's been
a bit different for us all these last 12
months
um the worker was part of the covered
response team for the council
so um actually conducted um
welfare calls to residents um helped
with their delivery of medicines
and more recently has helped with
processing their business grants that
the partnerships team have been
responsible for administering some of
them
um as you can imagine there are
various partnerships and groups out
there with a slightly different focus
but um we are um
linkedin with the joint financial
inclusion group
so this is again the chest field falls
over and northeast
health partnerships um this was started
back in 2019 um but over the last year
it's been
and the focus has been about
communication and informing residents of
where they can access
um services not just financial services
to be fair
um but you know health and well-being
and you may recall in the wind tradition
of the news there was like a one-page
um article with various you know helpful
numbers and things
um and um in chesterfield and bowls over
they actually did a leaflet drop but
we decided to put an article in the news
instead
um so moving forward that group will be
looking
um obviously covert you know is
inevitably going to be a driver for this
um but the partnership's quite wide um
so hopefully
it will you know minimize the
duplication we can share the knowledge
learning and understanding and moving
forward
um the clay cross obesity group is not
directly linked to the health
partnership
but people that sit on the health
partnership are also part of the group
i appreciate last year you received a
presentation
um on with regards to the work of that
group and i think kelly probably touched
upon it
in her presentation last last month so i
won't draw too much on that but
there are there are links but it's um
but it's more about the kind of the
officers
playing that kind of role in terms of
informing
um the partnership um
there's the place alliance which covers
northeastern bowls over
um and they have recently established a
mental health subgroup as well
um so this is it's quite the
place like this is quite strategic led
by the ccg
but the partners are quite wide um and
again
um i think this was it's recognized
um that local at the voluntary sector
and local groups can play quite a key
role in the preventative agenda for
health
rather than the kind of the reactive um
so that um i think having those partners
around the table
with with the place alliance will
hopefully
um help to kind of streamline um
future kind of future services future
projects
um the older people strategy i just
wanted to quickly mention it
obviously the northeast dubba shorter
people strategy is a council owned
strategy
it's not partnerships but um
there is a link and what we're what
we're hoping
is that because the overarching
priorities older people
and that we can utilize the partners
around
the table um in terms of being able to
commission activity to support old
people
um and independence in the home um in
the long term
um the future um obviously
it's a little bit unknown at the moment
but
um one of the projects that we're just
about to progress
um again is funded through through the
health partnership through public health
is a digital connect project um
so on the back of um
recognition that people particularly
older people have
embraced technology um to access
services to speak to family and friends
during
um during the last 12 months um
there's recognition that and there are
still some barriers
um that are stopping people from doing
more or
accessing more services the recent um
questionnaire we uh they we did as a
council it's the digital services survey
um interestingly that threw up the three
main barriers
and people felt was lack of skills um
confidence and security so
um although this is a health partnership
project it you know it would be silly of
us to ignore
what what the results of that survey was
telling us so
what which what we're hoping is that
this project will
get more people digitally included um
you know to help um help with accessing
services
and social interaction breaking down
those social
isolation barriers um and almost kind of
like carrying on with the momentum
people have gained as a result of um
you know moving online and i've also
been forced to move online over the last
year over the last
year um the final thing to mention
um although it's it's still in the
pipeline and we don't have any detail
um there might be some ring-fenced
funding from public health with regards
to mental health
and possibly with young children um
so whether that's channeled through the
health partnerships directly
i'm not entirely sure there's not much
detail out there yet
um but um i think this is again on the
recognition that uh the the longer-term
impact that kobe has had
um on mental health so um yeah
so hopefully over the next few months
we'll get we'll get more detail about
that
um so that's it from me i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you tris uh very in-depth report
there
has anyone got any questions or comments
they'd like to raise
i can always see one handed that's
council welton
you're myself yeah i think i think
councillor lilly was ahead of me bye
counselor lilly sorry you're on the
other screen
your mics off council lovely
it's still off ah yeah
thanks chet um basically i'm i'm proud
to be
uh suggesting that i was at the
at the beginning of this project uh at
its very inception and
i think the sentiments at that time was
to try and build something that's robust
and flexible
to such an extent whereby we can contain
and adapt
to any contemporary issues that arise
which they have
as you can see with the catalogue of
different things that that we're
contending with at this moment
in time from what i've seen that
robustness is still there
the will is still there obviously the
the
uh functions of economics and whatnot
was gonna have a
a massive impact on what's happening
plus i think
one of the possible drawbacks that we
might get from the
from the uh position with covid
is that people are reluctant to get out
there back into the
into the environment and into the
community because of the
fear of the unknown sort of thing but i
think because it's been built the
robustness
and flexibility is being built into the
system
and obviously you can see just by
looking at the catalog how
how successful it's been any emergencies
that can come along
including uh people sort of being
standoffish and not wanting to put
themselves in the firing line with
respect to
what all what's going on around them i
think the more we can do
to contain and push the the flexibility
and the strength of this
this partnership the the better it can
be
just one question though tris
right at the very beginning of this
project um
we've got involvement with the ccgs
now right at the at the inception the
ccgs are in the flexible mode
the move is shifting there are all sorts
of different changes
we've got different hubs being built and
demolished we've got
hubs disappearing one hub then three
hubs
and then i'm not i'm not up to speed on
where we are at this minute with regards
to the ccgs
and their involvement and depth of this
it would be nice to see that the cggs
have actually pulled back in and pulled
back together
got a decent grounding and are now
contributing in the fashion that we hope
right from the beginning he would be
able to do you see any goals for that
yeah i i think it's fair to say um
in in probably within the last year or
two um
the ccgs have become more involved um
we have regular representation from them
on our health partnership
um and um you know we we have a seat at
the table
at the place alliance as well um sort of
like with a northeast hat on and a
partnership hat
as well and so i think it's um
yeah i understand what you're saying in
terms of the
the concerns that the partnership had a
few years ago
particularly at the start um and the
engagement wasn't consistent but
it is now um and um and so
it's so it's it's you know much better
and
and that kind of relationship is is
there now
okay thank you tris um i've come to
council welter
yeah thank you thank you chair i'm going
to start with my conclusion question and
i'll track back and
see what what i'm asking it is this the
appropriate sort of project or projects
that should be
put into this vision derbyshire thing
that is being pushed by
by uh the county leader and everything
and re the reason why i'm i'm asking
that is
i'd start by looking at what's in what's
in here and to me
you should say public health nhs
county children's services county adult
adult services that's where
responsibility lies
and when i'm looking at it from a
scrutiny district point of view
i'm always keen that we look at what's
in our area of responsibility and when
we bring something we're looking to
analyze look at the objectives see what
works what doesn't work looking at
whether the performances work can we do
things better
so this is something and i think i think
that i apologize for taking the phrase
maybe out of context in minimizing
duplication
so what why why are we the agent or
manager for this there may be very very
good reasons for it but if it is
something that crosses or has to cross
all those
different boundaries of chesterfield
borough council in the county and
everything
is this something that should be put
forward for this this
vision derbyshire um
i have to say i'm i'm not too familiar
with the d television derbyshire
um unfortunately but from from my
understanding i wasn't here at the start
um but the principle um
of each and boring district having a
health partnership
um it was um something that public
health wanted to do
to to enable um
partners at a local level that know
their communities
and to be able to adapt funding um
and so that local approach was adopted
um across the county um
in terms of the linkage division
derbyshire um
i'd have to to go back in and and have a
look at the detail of that
and that said i know that there are
members of
on the health partnership that are um or
are familiar with asian derbyshire
and i'm sure if there was um possible
duplication
that that would be you know that would
be brought to the table
um and um but i can certainly go
you know i can go and find out for you
should you want me to yeah it's very
very quickly but i mean what i'm
interested in is
obviously is accountability and how we
improve things and you improve things
where you know you've got responsibility
for that particular area
uh virgin garbage we've all got very
different views on it's very embryonic
but we've been told that is
to consider things like climate change
environmental policies
that do cross all these boundaries
that's why i'm asking if it's something
for that because
otherwise i'd be asking things like
where's the accountability for the
partnership and everything you do who
who actually says whether these
individual things have been a success or
not
and how do we you know how do we how do
we come to a conclusion on that
um i probably suppose it's fair to say
with public health being the funder
and when um you know the
projects and the ideas of commit
commission through the partnership
um and then it's the partnership that
has that scrutiny
um as well so um the successors or not
are reported to that to the partnership
um and um we're kind of the
you know the mechanism um
yeah we just kind of manage the funding
on behalf of the partnership
um but the accountability is with the
partnership and then ultimately back to
public health at
county
okay thank you tris has that answered
your questions council welcome
um yeah yeah because i believe it's a
common theme about you know sort of just
i mean these are all really worthy
they're all really good things to do
it's just knowing that they are
somewhere there's democratic
accountability we are a scrutiny
committee
if it's not us who who is it to ensure
are things being done the right way
should we do things differently
um you know it's it's all about really
thank you i'm looking for
anyone else got their hand up check
count to the barkers indicating he'd
like to speak
yeah council their game is reading thank
you
is it me me face i don't want to go fast
okay yeah
just following on from richard really i
i i i see your point which is that i
forget that
so the question is is it
the county council's responsibility then
to really hold
this partnership to account uh uh
through their scrutiny process so public
health
uh i think there's a scrutiny uh people
one or a
health one of the county would it would
it be
that scrutiny committee a county that
looked that sort of
uh scrutinized as your
or the partnership's effectiveness is
that am i writing that
does that make sense i don't know yes
yeah um
well yes because with with public health
um funding all the locality partnerships
across the county
ultimately that you know that that
responsibility would lie with them but
obviously
what the approach and the reason why
they wanted to have the locality
approach was to make sure that
you know partners at a local level um
uh could adapt to um
issues residents were facing um
conscious that you know
not all the wards in the district never
mind in the in the county
have the same issues with regards to
kind of health
um you know the the kind of geographical
um barriers that some areas have that
others don't
um so i think that was the whole premise
of um establishing these locality
partnerships was to enable
that rather than it all being
administered
centrally from matlock you know from
county
um but uh but yes ultimately i suppose
with it being
public health it goes back to them
okay thank you thank you council backer
council gomez rini i believe you had
your hand raised
thank you chair um yeah i was just gonna
say i'm in
on uh i'm just have a look at page 13 of
the report
um first thing to point out 1.26 with
the mental health i think that's
fantastic i was pleased to see that and
i'll definitely be keeping an eye out on
the details released on that
uh just looking at point four
sorry um so alternative options and
reasons for rejection so alternative
options were covered in the cabinet
report on the 18th of february 2016.
uh apologies if i'm uh making myself
sound a bit silly
i suppose what i was just wanting to to
ask you know i think really it
sort of ties in to cancel the welton and
councillor barker
but do we i mean is this something that
that the cabinet would would review on a
yearly basis so would they have a look
at you know for example these types of
reports
you know what what's happened each year
and you know what what the funds are
moving forward and i suppose
probably more importantly you know that
um
sort of things in place with uh with
covered and restrictions now we're going
to work around them
um i historically um
there has been a report taken to cabinet
about the health partnership
um i think one was meant to go last year
but it was um he didn't go because of
what was happening with
um with covid but um i wasn't around in
2016
um so i don't know kind of the the
background
um in terms of the conversations had
within
within our council um but
um i mean i suppose ultimately yes um if
this is something
and you know that um you know to go an
informed cabinet
like say historically that has been done
before um
but um it's i suppose it's quite um
i'll say it's not an unusual um position
but
obviously the you know it's external
funding
um that um is benefiting north east
residents but absolutely there needs to
be that degree of um you know are we
doing the right things for the right
reasons
um you know i suppose is the main
question and
um i'd like to think so
okay thank you does that answer your
question
thank you i believe we've got council
welton and councillor berkey
just just very very quickly picking all
of this i i think it is important that
any initiative and it's a bit very
worthy everything that's been done
has a relevant body that looks over it
at some stage now
whether that's district cabinet whether
that's district
it seems it's more likely going to be as
council barca said
it is county county scrutiny could come
in if they want to then have to
so i think it just it it's important
that this ends up somewhere
um with somebody being able to look at
it and saying
yeah it's all brilliant and it's doing
it the right way from a political
democratic
objective over the officers so that's my
final point on it
councillor burking thank you chair
um i think on on that last point of
council welton's is
it is there a two-part approach
obviously county are responsible for
um sharing out sharing out the various
finance that's
that's been made available to them so
they will have a responsibility to make
sure that that is used properly
but i think as trisha said it's been
that the tasks themselves have been um
delegated if that's the right word down
to always at local level because we've
got more
um intimate knowledge of what we would
need at local led
level and as she said herself there are
variations within that
uh even within within within districts
let alone across the county
so i think there's that two two-part
approach there the overview
will be county we've got the cash in the
first place but then ourselves and maybe
our cabinet as well as we are doing now
to to make sure that that money that we
have got is being spelt spent properly
in the
uh to cover the uh problems that we've
got within our uh
within our area uh and coming on from
that sorry
my my my question is this seems to be it
seems to be a very very well
uh coordinated project covering loads of
loads of opportunities here i'm trying
to scribble i was trying to scribble
down some extras
as trish was reporting there trista you
find a danger
that um you know this there's so much to
do
that it that there's a there's a danger
that maybe some of the issues will
will just drop off the end of the line
um i suppose it's difficult um a
obviously
it's not a massive amount of money um
to um you know for the district but it's
clearly better than nothing um and so i
i think
with the with the overarching priority
being older people um which is
which is something that um you know the
partnership agreed
um and i so i suppose that's that's the
guide
that's the guide for us because of who
we've got on the partnership you know we
do
have um people from public health you
know
that know the stats that know the
details of
of the current health issues um
obviously on a county-wide basis but
on a locality basis um
so i think it's it's you know utilizing
that partnership approach to make sure
we understand what the issues are and we
and we
do our best to react and it's not i
think it's important to say that it's
not just about
um the the money as well it's it's the
partnership working and the networking
at the at the meetings where you you
know you've got people
um oh i'm doing this project i'm doing
this activity and somebody says oh
i know someone who can help or i can
refer or
all of a sudden we're jump we're joining
up and avoiding that duplication so
it's it's not just about um kind of
funding activity it's it's broader than
that as well
and hopefully because of that we
know we try not to to lose too much
okay tris thank you if there's no more
questions
there's a question from councillor
literature
just one second yes counselor yeah
basically when it was first set up
all of this sort of criteria was put
together uh to make
some sort of guiding principles i think
the main principles that were worked
along with the
question of the six w's who what when
where why and how and i think those
principles have held the thing together
so that
you're not just looking at the funding
area of course it's an important area
but it's who's going to do what when why
and how and
it's all got to fill in to justify
the end sort of justification just to
say yes
the project should be included it should
go ahead it should it should
give it a chance and whatever else some
principles have been a bit
lost along the way um for whatever
reason
and some some of the partnerships have
dropped
to the wayside that's why i question
with regards to the
ccgs as it's because i see that as a
very important area
but still i still believe that the
principles of the six w's
held together as they were initially
wanted to be or intended to be in in
their first instance
can give a strong and sure grounding to
make sure that this project
carries on gets stronger it gets more
flexible more robust
and it does what we want it to do and
that is to achieve what
those people out there want of it
okay thank you council just if you have
if there's no more further questions or
comments chris i'm gonna
just spare me a second to flip through
nope i'm going to thank you very much
for your time thank you for coming today
and thank you for your report you're
welcome to stay
obviously you're also welcome to leave
us
thank you no i um i'll um i will go but
no thank you for um
for inviting me and um allowing me to
to come and bring you the progress of
the health partnership and
obviously with it being such unusual
times for us all
um you know it's it's there have been
some some
nice stories so uh but are you more than
welcome thank you
thanks very much bye okay
okay if we move on to
item number five which is
the parks and green spaces which should
be included in your
information packs so it's pages 17-23
and i believe we've got darren mitchell
joining us from
he's the street team manager i don't
know
here already or is he he's in the
waiting room chair would you like me to
admit him
yes please thank you
[Music]
it's popped up on my screen
he's come up on the screen and the
camera's not on yet though
lots of it difficulties but i think in
here
see us yes sorry about that
technology's fine when you want to work
it
okay we'll just give you a second okay
i don't think i was expecting yourself
steve i thought you were on holiday
uh i was supposed to be
it got me third and i was intending
taking the
time off but uh other things events have
uh dictated that i've not been off so
good afternoon everybody good afternoon
we've got both of you this afternoon
then yeah
made him funny yeah
okay stephen down uh you don't mind if
we call you by those things
no no no problem thank you very much
i think you know everyone in the uh
communities
committee so uh we'll just carry on
which is item number five
which is a look at the report that
you've sent to us thank you very much
for the report
um i know i've got a few um sorry this
spreadsheet not before
i know i've got a few questions um but
i'll open it up to uh everyone else
first
if they've got any questions about the
spreadsheet
if there's none i shall start
i can see oscar go madrini your hand was
up yes oscar
sorry one i was uh i was willing to let
you go first but go on central
um hi both uh so yeah thanks for
sending us the uh the information over
it was more than useful
the i suppose the first question i got i
was having a look at the
um inspections with the arcs
and i was just wanting some clarity
because i've done the maths
and i could see that 2021 we spent 18
522 pounds and 63 pens
and with the parks i mean the they're
all
you know what's the there's no two
figures the same that i can see
and i was just wanting to know because i
understand that we do the inspections
in-house
so i was just wanting to ask about also
the costume you know how it's worked out
where the figures
are from etcetera um so yeah if you're
able just to sort of give us some
information on that the materials
themselves
or the prices for things like materials
and parts
this is the the inspection expense
okay inspection costs vary
depending on the size of the site and
the amount of equipment on each site
um it could be that certain sites have
got large areas of tarmac which we have
to sweep and clear as part of it
it's not just the play equipment itself
it's this surrounding
area as well so you could have such a
large site like
i think charlie park is one of the
higher ones
because it's such a bigger sigh there's
more time spent there by the individual
teams
undertaking the inspections and actually
doing the litter picking while they're
here and cleaning the bins
yeah and sweeping the surfaces but can i
just clarify then the actual inspection
uh that includes emptying bins and
cleaning the area yeah
yeah okay and do we do it so is it is it
based on
on um obviously the man hours as well
that's putting them so based on the
amount of time that they're there
so i you know cost per member of staff
at the park
yeah what what we base it on is uh we've
we've got a standard minute value um
for all our operations so each play
piece of play equipment has a
time allocated to it for the for the
the sorry we've got a lot of
interference at listen
um yeah so it's the time they so if you
go set its wings it may take five
minutes for him to undertake the
inspection regime
but while he's there he's then also that
might be the time to
sweep the surface underneath the swings
um so it's all allocated out
each set of item of play equipment is
allocated at a time
and then there's the surrounds the
fencing surrounds which majority of the
player grounds are either fenced in
um or it could be that uh if it's on
aggressive they're in a larger area
they'll
immediately litup or that surrounding
area
if i can just add to that as well in an
earlier uh information set that we
provided scrutiny
we gave an individual uh sheet
for each particular play site that set
out how many numbers of swings
slides multiplayer units and and they
have the time values and at the bottom
tell you the amount of time that's
allocated for cleaning emptying bins
inspecting slide swings multiplayer
units so that's
that's typically the
snap hours that's allocated that
particular site
so you've just done that then um how
often do we inspect each side
monthly monthly other than
skate parks they're inspected weekly
am i out just to ask another chair
absolutely um yes i was just gonna ask
her
because i know that we're saying that
obviously we've not got well
i don't think there is a budget for
parks is the council
so i mean i'm assuming obviously with
inspections you know we don't have any
set budget it's just case of however
much it cost per year is
you know the amount that we end up
spending if you like
um not not not exactly so some years ago
we used to have an individual budget for
platforms
and we had individual budgets uh a
number of
uh activities but as we started
rationalizing
uh management and administration
arrangements
all the grounds maintenance activities
uh was were simulated to one
overall budget so all the material
subjective budgets in various costs uh
budget cost centers
were brought into one and all the
salaries and labor from
battle costs were all brought into one
so whereas before we probably had 20 or
30 individual
uh service function activity budgets
we've now predominantly got one
where all the staffing uh et cetera it's
one
uh overall grounds maintenance operating
account
which makes it it's very
uh effective and efficient from a an
accountancy point of view but from a
management
information point of view it's difficult
to drill it back down
okay thank you
does anyone else have any bunch of
questions i can see
council burkin i think you're next
thank you chair um can i just ask
gentlemen
uh where you get your standard minutes
from and uh
how often are they updated please the
seven-minute values uh
were produced
in wow where would we be uh
the mid to late 2000s
no they probably the the early to mid
2000s
we had uh consultants in uh
to actually develop these because there
is
uh a lacking of this uh child
information
through uh throughout the public sector
uh
we have shared this with our authorities
uh
in the past uh back in the
late 90s early 2000s a lot of the grass
maintenance activities were what we call
unmeasured
there was no realistic allowed time
value
so we we did over the course of some
several years
uh get time measurement values
so that we could calculate
a fair day's wage for a third day's paid
and the four uh compulsory competitive
tendering arrangements
had a massive influence in us uh
putting those in place to ensure that we
were competitive
and efficient obviously
thank you
is there anyone else
there's no one else with a hand up steve
or darren so i'll just ask a couple of
things
and of all the parks we've listed all 27
i counted
that's about right for yourself they're
all owned by northeast archer
um i've counted that there are four
within the projected life span of the
park
so of the 27 only four fall in the
projected life
lifespan so is there any
any uh i mean i don't know how to put it
is there any budget set at the moment to
bring these parks back up today
not not from a capital point of view
projected life um i don't think we
put in general lifespans on we would
just assume some
for this exercise that we're going to
take with yourselves
and when you purchase a park initially
and the install will give you something
like
10 years on wet poor or 20 years on wet
board or
this metal equipment they'll guarantee
the equipment for like 20 years
so that that was the the lifespan i was
looking at and
again it brings in a couple of questions
some of them depend on which one it was
it was
quarry road play area that's got a
projected lifespan of between four and
27 years which i thought was a
um yeah strange
may i respond to that guy yeah the
reason behind that
is um there has been various bits of
bobs of
new equipment put on quarry lane site
over a course of the last
probably 15 years from developers 106
money
so where we've had a 106 funding been
provided to upgrade that site
a new piece of equipment's going on so
that's probably why there's a different
scale of
what was there before and what we've
upgraded and added to that
okay thank you
let me just go
um just touching on the 106 money if you
don't mind uh
rnc i've spoke to
um planning and at the moment we've got
approximately 25
new house major housing developments
going ahead this year
and they're predicting between five and
ten new play areas being built this year
i mean what's the scope within
within the current system to
maintain those or look after them and
the way i understand it is once they put
in they then hand it over to the
district council to become our
responsibility
well it depends on who's the landowner
because don't just come to the district
the 106
would it may also fund parish sites um
it's it's dependent on where the
development is and the locality
to a existing site which they believe
it'd be more beneficial to upgrade
and we work closely with polish councils
on that so
a lot of a lot of the sites that we are
going to be getting are all going to be
parish council
which we upgraded for the parish
okay can you just explain that a little
bit more then so the 106 money would
upgrade the parish site but we'd still
be responsible for it is that right
no no no the responsibility still lies
with the parish council
but because we're maintaining the site
we get the
commuted sum for maintenance for a
period of 10 years
so instead of us recharging the parish
back for that
we'll do the maintenance um on that side
for a period of 10 years
up until that money is run out as
extinct as
all if the parish is a site where
they look after their own equipment
obviously then that maintenance commuted
some
will go to the parish direct
if you recall at the last scrutiny uh
meeting we talked about
with all these uh new horizons there was
a lot of little
insignificant players that were popping
up
so through the actual planning process
when planning consult with us on
uh developments if we believe that
there's an over provision in a
particular area we may say to planning
well we don't particularly want to
a new uh play area on this particular
estate
we will third to have a community some
more 106
monies to invest in other facilities
uh in that locality and and that would
explain
the variance in the quarry role player
where you've got four to 27 years
because it is a large site
and monies we've received from other
developments in that area we've put
other new equipment into that site
to develop it further and make them a
more of a
a more wide and varied site with greater
player value
the more strategic sign okay
thank you does anyone else
have any more questions
just having a look through i don't think
there is
i think that's uh that could be
everything
thank you for the report and thank you
for attending today
okay pleasure thank you good afternoon
everybody hold on
hold on steve with the uh recycling mate
you did a good job
thank you we get we're getting there
hopefully
bye-bye
okay
we'll move on to item number six then
which is the upon
forward plan for executive decisions the
links on the page
and does anyone have any this is just to
be notified
yes chair it's we have it every every
time but obviously if there's any
queries members have i can pass them on
to the governance team to
to chase up okay thank you
does anyone have any queries or points
you wish to make
no thank you well i've
gone to item number seven which is the
work program which is page 24
to 28.
again i don't think there's anything
particular in here
it's uh again just to be noted is that
correct
yes chair it's just setting out what
you'll do at your last meeting
obviously um you'll be finalizing your
report that you're going to decide on
today
and then the other two main items are
the review of community safety
partnership which you require
statutorily to do at this committee once
a year
and then you'll have steve back actually
to do the update on the street scene
service and how it's been doing on
things like recycling
okay anyone have any points or questions
you wish to raise
i can't see i don't think so thank you
[Applause]
does anyone have any additional urgent
items that wish to raise
thank you which brings you on title
number nine which is
the date of the next meeting which is
the 14th of may
at 1 30.
check can i just confirm sorry with that
i'm just thinking
are we still expecting that to be over
uh zoo
you want me to respond chair yes please
sue
i anticipate it will be a chair um
obviously
you'd hope sometime in the near future
that will be starting to get back to
normal but
that's quite at the sort of the end of
the period before
obviously june where we're hoping a lot
more will open so at this moment
unless governance know any better i
would expect it to be on zoom
okay thank you sir
if there's another phone yeah i i can't
i can't make that i've got
so give my apologies it's a friday
thanks
i've got people in
item number 10 uh
i move that the public be excluded from
the meeting during discussion of the
following items
business to avoid the disclosure to them
with any exempt
information as defined in paragraph one
paragraph
five one part one schedule 12a the local
government act 1972.
uh i believe we can now
finish the live stream is that correct
you